[Music]
the multi-talented singer and rapper
celebrated her 26th birthday by throwing
a star-studded birthday bash on
wednesday night at delilah in la the
theme under the sea
very sexy
[Music]
[Applause]
as far as costumes the birthday girl
dressed up as princess keita from
atlanta's the lost empire
welcome to the city of atlantis billy
eilish was photographed outside rocking
a lobster getup in winnie harlow and
karuchi tran stunned in mermaid inspired
ensembles
when it comes to the party normani was
doing what she does killing it on the
dance floor and cheers to another year
dozier took a moment to celebrate by
taking shots with her crew everything's
getting better with time back in march
it spoke with doji cat at the grammys
about what an incredible year this has
been for her and her career people like
what i'm doing and that that's that's
all that matters i i'm i like my music
and if other people like it that just
amps it up it amps up my feelings my
emotions about it and
it i'm working with people who i really
believe in who i i look up to and that's
that like that's all i wanted those only
people i want to work with so when that
comes out when people find out who those
people are that's going to be
interesting and fun happy 26th birthday
to an artist who always keeps it like
she said interesting and fun
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you